>>presenter: So, good afternoon everyone.
I wanted to welcome you to another outstanding
Authors@Google Talk. Now, one thing that I
wanted you to keep in mind while I give my
intro, is I wanted you to specifically pay
attention to any time I reference the University
of Illinois, of YouTube, or the word "indeed."
We are indeed very pleased to be joined today
by a Nobel Prize winner, Chris Chabris, for
today's talk. I take that back. He's actually
an Ig Nobel Prize winner, which is pretty
much the same thing except the speeches are
shorter and the talks are a little bit more
meaningful. Along with his colleague, Dan
Simons, Chris has created a landmark video,
which I'm sure many of you have seen. It is
called "The Invisible Gorilla" and he'll probably
talk about that at length today during our
conversation. And it's went viral on YouTube.
Many of you have probably seen it. I remember
when I saw it for my first time viewing, I
am actually a graduate of the University of
Illinois in Champaign, and so Dan works there
and I thought for certain that the elevator
in the movie was our elevator in the psychology
building. So, I was paying attention to that
for the entire program. I missed everything
else and it turns out the elevator was at
Harvard. So, I was clearly mistaken. But,
I didn't get to see the bonus feature. Now,
Chris received his PhD from Harvard and now
he's an Assistant Professor of Psychology
at Union College. His research focuses on
cognitive illusions and perception, and also
group behavior and group think. And he's published
papers on everything from beauty to the Mozart
effect to the beauty of the Mozart effect.
He'll be speaking to us today about his latest
book, which is entitled "The Invisible Gorilla".
It speaks about how perception affects the
gorillas in our midst. Indeed, truth is all
around us if we're only there to see it. Be
sure, as the talk goes forward, to count any
instances of passes, both aerial and bounce
passes. Without further ado, please join me
in welcoming Chris to Google. Thank you.
[applause]
>>Chris Chabris: Thank you very much. I'm
glad you got in that "Ig" part of the Ig Nobel
Prize. I have students who sometimes write
to me and say, "Oh, I'd be very honored to
work with a Nobel Prize winner on research."
And I usually don't write back and explain
that they made a mistake. I just let them
keep on believing that. So, I'd like to start
today by showing you a famous experiment in
selective looking. And this is not, perhaps,
the experiment you're thinking of. This is
actually an experiment done by Ulric Neisser,
one of the pioneers of cognitive psychology,
in the 1970s. And this is the experiment that
inspired Dan Simons and I to do the Invisible
Gorilla experiment that many of you know about
and that we'll talk about shortly. What Neisser
did in the 1970s was create a video showing
six people passing two basketballs around.
Three people are dressed in white and three
people are dressed in black. And your task
is to focus on the people dressed in white
and count the number of times they pass the
ball, and to do this counting silently in
your head. And at the end of the video, you'll
be asked a question about it. OK, so, can
I have a volunteer? Oh, come on. Don't be
shy. I'm gonna start cold calling if I don't
get any volunteers. 24. OK, the volunteer
even knew the question I was gonna ask. OK,
24 passes. Now, raise your hand if you notice
something else besides the people throwing
the ball around. What did you notice?
>>audience #1: [inaudible].
>>Chris Chabris: Excuse me?
>>Chris Chabris: The lady with an umbrella,
right. So, in Neisser's original study, a
woman carrying an umbrella walks through during
the passing of the basketballs. But if you
notice this, if you look at this video carefully,
you don't even have to look very carefully,
you can see that it's unusual. For one thing,
everyone's a ghost in this video. And the
way Neisser created this was using a technique
with mirrors to record several videos and
then project them together and make a video
where everyone overlaps at once. And this
experiment had been known somewhat in the
psychology community, but I personally was
not aware of it. Dan knew about it. Dan Simons
knew about it when he and I met at Harvard
University in the late 1990s. And there was
a little bit of suspicion that maybe the reason
why people don't notice this woman walking
across the screen is that everyone's a ghost
and she's actually a little bit hard to see.
And there are strange things; people are walking
through each other and so on. Does it really
demonstrate something important? How fragile
is that ability to notice these unexpected
objects? So, unexpected events. So, Dan and
I were teaching a course in research methods
to the undergraduates at Harvard. In this
course, each student was supposed to produce
their own experiment and collect data and
write it up at the end of the term. But Dan
had a great idea, which was why don't we make
it fun for everybody and have one experiment
that we can all work on together as well.
Now, there aren't that many psychology experiments
which require ten or twelve people, but Dan
knew about Neisser's experiment and decided
we should film it and recreate it in the Psychology
Department, but with a few twists. So, one
of those twists was going to be that we would
do it live with everybody moving around in-between,
in and out and so on so that if we still found
that people didn't notice something unexpected,
it wouldn't be because everybody was a ghost.
The other twist was to try some things other
than a woman carrying an umbrella. Maybe a
woman carrying an umbrella is kind of hard
to see because it's not that surprising; it's
not that unexpected. What about something
else? Well, one of the other professors in
the department had a gorilla suit lying around
in his lab. Someone always has a gorilla suit
lying around, right? So, we borrowed that,
that's "borrowed" and had one of our students
put the gorilla suit on and walk across in
the video. And we wound up producing a video
that looks somewhat like this next one. And
here again, even if you know about this already,
I'd like you to really try it for yourself
and try hard to focus on the people wearing
white shirts and ignore the people wearing
black shirts, and count the number of times
the white-shirted people pass the ball. And
once again, I'll ask you at the end how many,
how many you counted. Here we go.
Ok, so what's the count on that one?
>>audience #2: 16.
>>Chris Chabris: 16. OK, most people got 16?
All right. Raise your hand if you noticed
a gorilla walking across the screen. OK, did
anyone not notice the gorilla? OK. Raise your
hand if you noticed anything else unusual.
Ok, I only see like, three hands up in the
whole room. So, you sir, what did you notice?
>>audience #3: The curtains changed from red
to yellow.
>>Chris Chabris: The curtains changed from
red to yellow. So, raise your hand if you
noticed that the curtain changed from red
to yellow. I mean, you can see that it's yellow
now. OK, so I only see about two hands. Did
anyone notice anything else unusual? [pause]
You, sir.
>>audience #4: One of the people in the black
shirt left.
>>Chris Chabris: One of the people in the
black shirts left, that's correct. Did anyone
else notice that one of the people in the
black shirts left? OK, nobody. So, I fooled
you. You thought there was gonna be a gorilla
and you opened your mind to the possibility
the gorilla might appear. You were able to
prime yourself to notice a gorilla, but that
didn't mean that you were gonna notice all
the unexpected things that happened. There
were two other unexpected things that happened.
This is a video that was created by Dan Simons
this year. He calls it "the monkey business
illusion" and the idea is that expecting the
unexpected, or knowing that your attention
is limited and you might not notice things,
doesn't necessarily enable you to notice all
the unexpected things that are going on around
you. If you had known in advance that something
might change color, you might have picked
up on the curtain, but then you might not
have noticed the gorilla. So, there's no,
the trick to this is deeper than just something
you don't notice. [pause] In psychology jargon,
this phenomenon is known as "inattentional
blindness" now and this is a term that was
popularized by Arien Mack and Irvin Rock in
their book of the same name. And the idea
is that when we're not paying attention to
something, it can be as though we're actually
blind to it. It's as though the thing isn't
there or as though we don't see it at all.
It's not as though we should have catch a
faint glimpse of it, but not a really good
perception of it. When people are told afterwards
that there was a gorilla walking across in
our original video that they didn't see, they
don't suddenly say, "Oh, yeah. There was a
gorilla, but I just forgot to mention it to
you." Instead, they say, "No way. There was
no gorilla there." Or, in the original experiment
where we had video tapes, they said, "Well,
show me the tape again," and we would rewind
it and play it again and they'd say, "Well,
that wasn't there in the first place. Maybe
you switched the tapes on me or used some
kind of sleight of hand or something like
that." On the other hand, people who see the
gorilla, or probably the people who saw the
color change or the person walk away this
time, think it's very clear and obvious and
they are surprised that other people missed
it. So, as we thought about this experiment
more and more, we realized that it wasn't
just telling us something about inattentional
blindness, it wasn't just a dramatic demonstration
of inattentional blindness and incidentally,
just to illustrate how dramatic a demonstration
this is, other researchers later ran this
experiment using an eye tracking device, which
records exactly where subjects are looking
at all times and found that some subjects
who missed the gorilla in the original video
had actually looked right at it for up to
a full second and still missed it. So, it's
not just that their eyes happened to be pushed,
pointing the wrong way. There's actually some
kind of cognitive blindness to this thing.
And that's really interesting, but the more
we thought about it, the more we thought there
was something even more surprising about it.
And that was, in fact, the surprise that people
have about the results of this experiment.
It really conflicts with some deep belief
we have about how our minds work. Something
about our experience tells us that we really
should be noticing all the important things
that happen, especially if they're right in
front of our eyes and they last for a full
nine seconds, like our original gorilla thumping
event did. And this belief that we're noticing
and paying attention to much more of the world
around us then we really are, is what we've
called the illusion of attention. The illusion
is that we're noticing and paying attention
to far more than we actually are. Now, we
call this an illusion deliberately. It's in
some ways by analogy to visual illusions.
So, this is a famous visual illusion. Look
at these two tables and raise your hand if
you think the table on the left is longer
than the table on the right. OK, so I'm gonna
raise my hand, too, because to me, the one
on the left definitely looks longer than the
one on the right. Now, if I had a nice, clever
animation, I could rotate that table on the
left and overlay it on the table on the right
and you would see that they are the exact
same dimensions in all respects. And it is
a pure illusion that the one on the left looks
long and narrow and the one on the right looks
wide. It has to do with perspective and the
way our perceptual system actually wants to
experience a three-dimensional world as opposed
to something projected on a two-dimensional
screen. But no amount of, no amount of knowing
what I just told you is gonna make it look
any different; it still looks longer. It's
an illusion, it's built in to the way our
perceptual systems work and we would argue
that illusions like the illusion of attention
are built in to the way we think about our
own minds. I see someone there going like
this and trying to like, imagine it. If I
had a stick up there I could prove it to you.
I could stretch a stick out and then move
it around. That's what I do when I teach this
to students. Trust me on this one. It's really
built in to the structure of how we understand
our own minds. I see someone who's still doing
it; they still don't believe me.
[laughter]
Trust me, please. I'm up here giving a talk.
You're supposed to trust me. So, so, this
illusion of attention, the more we thought
about it, we realized was actually an example
of a more general phenomenon about the mind
and we call this the idea of every day illusions.
So, I'm gonna get a couple of definitions
out on the screen now for what I'm going to
be talking about for the rest of the time
today. Every day illusions are intuitive,
commonsense beliefs that we all have about
how our own minds work that are systematically
wrong, not easy to overcome, and can get us
into big trouble if we aren't aware of them.
Now, one way the illusion of attention can
get us into big trouble is the way that it
causes us to talk on our cell phones while
we're driving. The illusion causes us to talk
on our cell phones while we're driving because
it convinces us that we're able to see and
notice everything we need to do while we're
driving just as well when we're talking on
a phone as when we're not talking on a phone.
The illusion of attention tells us that because
we have this rich perceptual experience, we
see the road in front of us. It's not like
we're looking someplace else to talk on the
phone. We see the road in front of us; we're
getting the same visual input hitting our
retinas and going into our visual systems
and so on, that we must be noticing and perceiving
all the important stuff out there. And that's
actually not true. When you're talking on
the cell phone, you're depleting a central
resource of attention that actually applies
to all perceptual modalities and to thinking
in general, not just vision. So, talking on
the phone, even though that's an auditory
language task, decreases your ability to notice
unexpected things. And it's noticing unexpected
things which is really what keeps you out
of most accidents on the road. You know when
someone cuts you off or when someone goes
into the walkway or when you're in somebody's
blind spot and so on. If we didn't have this
illusion, if we really understood how limited
our perceptual inattention systems would be,
we probably wouldn't do things like talk on
cell phones. And of course, incidentally,
by the way, it's not holding the phone that's
the problem, it's not the number of hands
you have driving, it's the amount of your
mind you have paying attention to the task
of driving. So, hands free phones don't really
solve the problem, either. Now notice that
I said that these illusions are intuitive
beliefs. So, by intuition, I mean a kind of
rapid thinking that we aren't even aware we're
doing most of the time. Intuition is what
we're using when we make a quick judgment
or decision without thinking about it, which
is to say that intuition comprises most of
the thinking we do in our lives. Now I realize
that there are other definitions of intuition.
Some people think of intuition as some kind
of spiritual phenomenon where you just sort
of come into contact with the truth or something
like that, through some ineffable process.
That's not really what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about rapid thinking and decisions
made without reflection. So when we pick up
the cell phone and talk while we're driving,
we're doing that because of an intuition that
tells us that we're not driving any worse.
We haven't really stopped to analyze the problem
very carefully or think about research on
attention and so on, we just go with it. We
don't feel like we're driving any worse when
we're talking on the phone. So that's, those
are every day illusions and in our book, we
talk about six every day illusions. I'm gonna
talk about the rest of them for the rest of
this talk and as well as that, I'm gonna talk
about intuition a little bit. Here's another
example of an everyday illusion. This one
is called the illusion of memory. The illusion
of memory is the idea that our memories are
more complete, detailed, accurate, permanent
and objective than they really are. Those
qualities detail, accuracy, permanence, objectivity
and completeness are qualities that we act
as though our memories have in much greater
abundance than they really do. Now of course,
you may say, "Yeah, I don't remember what
I had for breakfast three weeks ago." I'm
not talking about that kind of memory failure.
I'm talking about something much larger than
that. For example, you're gonna see now a
video of an experiment done by Dan Simons,
my co-author of the book, and his colleague,
Dan Levin, when they were grad students at
Cornell. This is an experiment where an experimenter
would approach a pedestrian on a courtyard
on a quad. So here is the subject in this
experiment and here's the experimenter and
the experimenter simply, without telling him
anything about the fact that he's in an experiment,
says, "Please give me directions to the gym."
And there's not gonna be any audio here, but
it doesn't matter. You can see what, you can
see what happens next. So as he's giving directions,
two other people carrying a door have rudely
cut between the experimenter and the subject
and one of the people carrying the door switch
places with the original experimenter.
[laughter]
Now the guy left talking to the subject is
Dan Simons, himself, and you'll see shortly
that the subject actually, having looked earlier
directly at the first experimenter, now looks
directly at Dan for quite a while as he's
completing his instructions. And Dan now says,
"Oh, by the way, you were just a subject in
a psychology experiment and let me explain
to you what's going on. Did you notice that
I'm a different person than the one you were
talking about earlier?"
[laughter]
And, surprisingly in this experiment, the
response of about half of the participants
is, "No, I have no idea that you're a different
person." Some people notice it, some people
don't. And it's not just, this man, this is
an older gentleman, but it's not a function
of how old you are. Likewise, the ability
to notice the gorilla is not a function of
how old or young you are or how well-educated
you are, or whether you're intelligent or
stupid, or what your personality type is.
As far as we've been able to tell and other
research has been able to tell, these things
are built in features that are universal to
the human mind. Now we haven't gone into all
the countries of the world and tested these
things out, but as far as we can tell, at
least within our country and other places
where this has been studied, it's not some
kind of special personality trait or some
kind of reflection on the strength of your
mental abilities. It's a general property
of the human mind. In this case, the phenomenon
is known as change blindness. So, we can be
blind to significant changes in our visual
world if our attention is not called to those
changes while they're happening. So, if right
now, I blinked out of existence and was instantly
reproduced, replaced by a different person,
you guys would all notice, but that's only
because you would have seen the change. If
something distracted you, like a big billboard
came in front and I was replaced by someone
else, maybe someone else who is also a male
about 40 years old or something like that,
you might not notice the difference. Probably
most of you would, but some of you might not.
It's a surprising finding. You can't change
a man into a woman it turns out or a woman
into a man and in this way and have people
miss that. You typically can't change much
older people into much younger people, or
change say, a construction worker into a policeman
or a professor into a mailman, or something
like that. But that's about, that's about
it. What's going on here? Well, our memories,
it seems, are encoding much less detail about
the world around us or if they're encoding
it, they're dumping it very quickly and not
maintaining it for very long and that's not
the way we think our memories work. So this
is the illusion of memory; the idea that our
memories are more complete and permanent and
accurate than they really are. If you turn
it around and think about it a little bit,
why would we have this illusion of memory?
Or, put another way, why would our memory
systems be so limited? Some people say, "Well,
is that a defect? Like, how come we don't
save all that information?" And I could turn
it around and say, "Well, why would you want
to save all that information? Your brain would
get bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger,
accumulating all those details all your life
and if you built a big brain, in order to
be able to do that you'd never get out of
your mother during the process of being born."
There's a severe constraint on the size of
the brain and you just can't go on adding
functions willy nilly to it or else the species
won't continue on. And perhaps remembering
all the details we think we're remembering
is not really a very useful mental function
to have. Maybe remembering the kind of person
we're talking to and whether they're male
or female and simple categories is most of
what we, is most of what we really need. OK,
so let me show you one more example of this
change blindness phenomenon. I'm gonna show
you this example for two reasons. One, there's
a Google employee pictured in it. I don't
think he's here today, though. And two, when
we wanted to do more studies of this kind,
when Dan came to Harvard-- this initial study
was done at Cornell-- when Dan came to Harvard
and he started working with me, we wanted
to do more of this kind of thing, but the
Human Subjects Review Committee at Harvard
had a somewhat different view of this than
at Cornell and they said, "Well, you really
can't just go up to people on the street and
start experimenting with them without getting
their consent." And we said things like, "Well,
but people get approached for directions all
the time in Harvard Square. What's the big
deal? This kind of thing happens to people
all the time." And they said, "Well, no, you
really ought to get consent first." So we
came up with a different experimental setting
that enables, that enables us to get consent.
And here's an illustration of it from a program
that the BBC did several years ago. I've turned
off the sound so you won't be hearing the
narration, but I'll narrate it a little bit.
Now, what you're gonna see is first you're
going to see the two people and the subject.
We changed one of them into the other. You
might recognize the first guy, if any of you
know him here. Notice they're wearing different
color shirts and they have different faces,
different hairstyles. We set up a booth, set
up a counter in the Psychology Building and
put an "Experiment Here" sign and recruited
subjects in the basement and said, in the
lobby and said, "Why don't you go up and participate
in an experiment?" And when they came up out
of the elevator and they approached the counter,
they saw the first guy standing behind it.
And he said, "Here. Fill out this consent
form first and then the experiment will begin."
This is Dan, by the way, explaining this.
So, they fill out the consent form. Sometimes,
they would read it, but usually they would
just sign it, hand it back, and now this would
happen.
[laughter]
The first guy would duck down and the second
guy would come up and hand them a form and
say, "Go down to that room, go down the hall
to that room and you'll meet someone there
who will tell you about the rest of the experiment."
[laughter]
Now, crucially, what the consent form had
said was, "In this study, you're going to
be exposed, you're going to be exposed to
an event and you'll be asked questions about
it." But it didn't say when you're going to
be exposed to the event. So as soon as they
hand that consent form back with their signature,
the event starts right then.
[laughter]
And there, early in that point, not in the
mindset of, "I gotta be on guard. The psychologists
are gonna trick me now." And the rest of this
video will just show more examples of this.
So, in this case once again, a significant
percentage of people, when asked a few seconds
later, "Well, did you notice that the guy
who came back up from behind the counter was
a different guy than the one who went down?"
they said, "No, I had no idea." And one of
the ones you may see here, if I let the video
run on long enough, was an undergraduate at
Harvard--oh, here she is--this is Elisabeth
Kensinger who's now a very excellent, important
professor at BU studying memory, and she did
not notice the change. It turns out being
a professor who studies memory does not really
enable you to notice all these, all these
changes in the world--
[laughter]
in the world around you. We have a story in
the book about how a friend of ours told at
a party that Dan and I were both at, an entire
story that happened to me and not to him,
but pretending as though it was his own story
and he had completely forgotten the source
of that memory and thought he had experienced
himself the joy of sitting down next to Patrick
Stewart at dinner.
[laughter]
That happened to me, not to him.
And he studied, and he studies false memory,
incidentally.
[laughter]
So, well the video continues with more and
more of this. So, I've shown you two examples
of every day illusions that can have a significant
effect on how we perceive and understand the
world in our daily lives. I think there are
a lot of deeper applications of this kind
of thing beyond just these visual examples
we've shown you. Inattentional blindness or
the illusion of attention can apply to information
in general and the information that we think
we're paying attention to and using when we
make decisions, and change blindness and the
illusion of memory can apply in many different
circumstances. I mean, for one thing, I'm
not really here to provide advice on how to
live your life, but if you start fighting
with your husband or wife or boyfriend or
girlfriend or whoever about whose memory for
what happened a month ago is exactly right
and whose is wrong, you should just stop because
the chances are high that neither of you remembers
exactly what was said a month ago and you're
wasting your time and just getting mad at
each other without ever coming to any resolution.
[laughter]
On the other hand, if you're clever you might
consult your sent mail folder or your saved
messages folder or your calendar, because
it turns out nowadays we do leave a lot of
electronic trails that can help us reconstruct
the past that we didn't have before. And you
guys may know of even better tools to reconstruct
what you've been doing, your browser history
and so on. Sometimes you can use that to,
to figure out what's going on. OK, so enough
of this. It goes on and on with more people.
Some of them actually notice. I think this
person actually notices what's going on.
[laughter]
Yeah, so.
Some, some people do notice. By the way, I
don't know if any of you, if you noticed,
but Dan's wearing a different shirt than he
was at the beginning of this, of this video.
[laughter]
Once again, trust me on that one. OK, so now
I've showed you some of these illusions and
now I'm gonna switch gears to something different.
As Monty Python used to say, "And now for
something completely different." Gonna take
a little bit of a detour now into a poetry,
a poetry reading. It'll be very short.
[reads]
"How do I love thee?
Let me count the ways."
You might recognize this. This is one of the
most famous lines in all of English language
poetry. It's by Elizabeth Barrett Browning
from her work, "Sonnets from the Portuguese".
I think this was Sonnet number 43 out of 44.
And of course it goes on to enumerate various
different ways. Now, Elizabeth Barrett Browning
wrote these lines and the rest of it during
her courtship with Robert Browning. And there
they are. This is Elizabeth and that's Robert.
They make a really fine couple, I think, especially
by the standards of the 1850s. Remarkably
modern hairstyles. Now this, this book, even
though it came out in 1850, already by the
late 19th Century, it was very prized and
recognized as an important work. And in 1885,
a British book dealer and collector named
Thomas J. Wise, pictured here, was offered
for sale by another collector that he ran
into, a privately printed edition of the Sonnets
from the Portuguese, that the Brownings had
printed, or that Elizabeth Barrett Browning
had printed a few years earlier, before the
actual first known printing in the 1850 book.
And he paid ten pounds for this and got some
of his collector friends to also buy copies.
And he actually snapped up several copies
and started then selling them to other dealers
and collectors and libraries and other institutions
around the world. And after that, he began
discovering other similar works. For example,
something by, something by Tennyson. This
volume, this is actually the volume that Wise
discovered from 1887 and this was, once again,
a privately printed edition of something that
came out later in the first known edition.
So what Wise was discovering was all these
items which fit pretty well into the body
of an author's known work. It wasn't a completely
new work, but it was a new edition. And he
sold these around the world to collectors,
libraries, universities, and so on and did
this for many, for many decades. He became
known as Great Britain's best bibliographer
and book collector later in his life. Unfortunately
for Wise, in the 1930s, two younger British
book dealers conducted an investigation of
some of these pamphlets and discovered through
a variety of techniques that many of them
were fraudulent. That is, Wise had printed
them up himself, along with some conspirators
and was passing them off as originals. The
techniques these collectors, these dealers,
used to discover the fraud were of the deductive
logic varieties. So for example, on this one
right here, they noticed that these ornaments
that were used to decorate the cover had actually
not been designed until about 15 years after
the date on the cover of the pamphlet. In
the case of the "Sonnets of the Portuguese",
they put the paper under a microscope and
detected that it was made of wood pulp and
they knew that wood pulp was not actually
used to make paper in Great Britain until
the 1870s, so it could not have been printed
in that form in the 1840s. And they also identified
numerous other ways that the printings were
inconsistent with everything else that was
known fact about how books were made at the
time and these authors' works and so on. They
published their indictment, I mean a very
long book, explaining without really coming
right out and saying it, that Wise had committed
a fraud. Now, why did I tell you this whole
long, this whole long story? Well, here's
a case where scientific analysis and logical
deduction really proved that Wise had been
committing forgery for quite a long period
of time. He denied it, of course, but everyone
believes that he did. This story of detecting
forgeries using scientific analysis and the
contrast between that and the intuitive decisions
that were made by all the collectors and dealers
and libraries who saw this stuff and said,
"Well, this book looks good. This looks like
it makes sense. Superficially, it looks like
something we should add to our collection."
This may remind you of a story that you've
heard about if you read Malcolm Gladwell's
book "Blink", which is subtitled "The Power
of Thinking without Thinking". Now in Gladwell's
book, he begins by telling the story of a
ancient Greek statue, known as a Kouros, and
here's the, and this is an example I'm gonna,
what I'm gonna tell you is the myth of intuition.
Here's the statue. Now, this statue was discovered
and it was in the possession of a collector
from Switzerland who offered to sell it to
the Getty Museum in Los Angeles for ten million
dollars. And the Getty Museum commissioned
some scientific tests which suggested that
the marble the statue was made of was, in
fact, from ancient Greece, from the proper
time period and place as it would have been
if this were an authentic statue. So the Getty
forked over the ten million dollars and then
later they had some other collectors and art
historians and art experts look at the statue
and as Gladwell recounts in his book, they
said things like, "Well I hope you didn't
pay for this yet," or they said they felt
a revulsion or it left them feeling cold or
it just didn't look right. So they could tell
by looking at it that there was something
wrong with it that the scientific analysis
of the material in the statue couldn't, couldn't
tell. And Gladwell presents this as the triumph
of intuition. They were able to intuitively,
within a second or two, know that this was
wrong, know that it was a forgery, whereas
the scientific experts had not been able to
prove that and in fact, were convinced otherwise.
Gladwell uses this to open his case in this
book for the power of intuition, or as he
calls it, rapid cognition. Now incidentally,
the Getty Museum and various experts are not
yet in full consensus about whether this statue
is a forgery. For example, the caption in
their own catalog says, "About 530 B.C, or
modern forgery."
[laughter]
So, it's not completely, it's not completely
agreed yet that this is a forgery, but even,
but even if it is, what are we to make of
these two contrasting examples, one in which
intuition detected a fraud that scientific
analysis didn't and the one that I presented
of Thomas J. Wise, where intuition, intuitive
thinking wound up acquiring and spending a
lot of money on these things for collections
that turned out to be wasted money and only
really careful logical deduction and scientific
analysis proved him to be a forger? I think,
actually, that the Thomas J. Wise case is
probably much more representative of the relationship
between intuition and logical analysis in
the case of art forgeries. I will bet you
that many forgers go to their graves having
fooled everyone and never get detected. Usually,
it's a sort of intuitive thinking that accepts
these things as accurate and only scientific
analysis, or some kind of logical analysis
that proves them wrong. For example, the Hitler
Diaries were accepted as genuine and made
public in Germany, until it turned out that
the paper they were written on was made after
World War II. So, they could only have been
authentic if Hitler was down there in Brazil
writing them out or something like that, after
World War II was over, and sending them back.
Now, what we call the myth of intuition is
this idea that intuition has special powers
as a mode of thinking to figure things out
that rational analysis and other forms of
thinking cannot do. At this point, now statues,
even a ten million dollar statue, well it's
just statues, what's the big deal if people
think this way? Its fast, it's efficient,
doesn't cause too much damage, except to museums
and art collectors and they're not really
all that sympathetic. Who are the real victims
here? Well, at this point, this is where this
man comes into our story. In case you don't
recognize him, this is Bernard Madoff, the
biggest and most famous Ponzi schemer in world
financial history. Now what does Bernard Madoff
have to do with the myth of intuition? Well,
one thing that's not realized often about
Madoff is the real story of why he was not
caught before he wound up engaging in 50 billion
dollars worth of fraud and looting lots of
institutions and individuals out of all of
their funds? The whistle, the Inspector General
of the Securities and Exchange Commission
did an exhaustive report on this and documented
the fact that the SEC investigated Madoff
many times over the years because they had
received tips from people. They had their
suspicions that something was wrong. And here
he explains why they did not actually catch
Madoff. This is a quote from the Inspector
General of the SEC. He wrote, "In one of the
examinations that the SEC conducted, they
asked Madoff how he was able to achieve these
returns. Madoff's returns were extraordinary
and always consistent. He never had a down
period, no matter how bad the market. And
they asked him, "How are you able to do this?"
Bernie Madoff said to them that he had a 'gut
feel' of how to time the market. They asked
him, what is the basis for his gut feel. And
he said it was his observations of the trading
room. He said he could actually sit on the
trading room floor and 'feel the market' and
know exactly when to buy and exactly when
to sell. And Madoff always bought at the right
price, and always sold at the right price,
day after day, year after year. Inexplicably,
the SEC just accepted these answers and went
on." Now, I think the most important word
in this whole passage is one that they didn't
underline, and that is the word "inexplicably."
This behavior's only inexplicable if you forget
about the fact that people actually believe
that it is possible to use one's intuition,
or gut feels, to time the market and make
all kinds of other significant decisions in
ways that, in ways that rational analysis,
or logic, or other kinds of methods, thinking
can't match. So, it's only inexplicable if
you don't realize that that myth is out there
and that we think about intuition that way
a lot of the time. Now, this raises another
question, well how is, what else contributed
to Bernie Madoff's success? I think it's interesting
and it plays in to one of our other, one of
our other illusions. The whistle blower in
the Madoff case, Harry Markopolos, wrote extensively
about this. And he provides some interesting
quotes to explain what was going on in people's
minds when they encountered Bernard Madoff.
Well, Simona Suh, who was an investigator
in the SECs New York office, said that Madoff
[quote] "didn't fit the profile of a Ponzi
schemer in the world that we knew then." Now
what did she mean by this? Well, as Markopolos
tells us, 'There's a reason why Madoff was
able to pull off the largest financial crime
in history. Madoff was so smooth, so convincing
that even an experienced journalist like Mike
Ocrant, (who had uncovered other Ponzi schemes,)
came away from that interview doubting what
he knew to be true.' So, Ocrant had actually
investigated Madoff, determined that he was
a Ponzi schemer, and went to confront him
with this information and get his side of
the story, and at the end of the interview,
he wasn't even sure anymore himself. Ocrant,
himself, was the editor of an industry publication
for hedge funds said [quote] "He never complained;
he was responsive to every question. He did
it without hesitation. There wasn't even a
hint of guilt or shame or remorse." So, sometimes
the way criminals are able to pull off their
crimes is by exploiting what we call in the
book, the illusion of confidence. Interestingly,
the word "con man" has the same root as confidence.
The illusion of confidence has two aspects.
One of them is that we tend to interpret another
person's confidence, their smoothness, their
quick answers, their strong presentations
an indication of honesty, accuracy, truthfulness,
skill, competence, good memory, whatever it
is they're trying to convince us of, the more
confident they are, the more we believe them.
Now, it's of course perhaps true that people
who are right should be more confident, but
we over interpret that connection; we take
it for more than it actually is. Now, this
is our third every day illusion after attention
and memory. Now we're at the illusion of confidence.
Madoff is a little bit unusual as a criminal.
And he's like the James Bond master villain,
like in his secret hideout with all the fancy
gadgets and so on. This time it was at the
top of a skyscraper in New York, not in some
Caribbean island, but he's really not typical
of criminals. Most criminals are not as good
as Madoff; they don't get away with 50 billion
dollar schemes for that long. Most criminals
are actually fairly incompetent. So now, to
illustrate this point, I would like to ask
the person who received an envelope from me
earlier to please stand up now. I handed out
an envelope earlier to someone. OK. So can
you open that envelope and show us what's
inside? What is that?
>>audience #5: I'm assuming a fake bill for
one million dollars.
>>Chris Chabris: It's a one million dollar
bill, correct?
[audience #5 laughs]
OK, so what's your name, by the way?
>>audience #5: Jessica.
>>Chris Chabris: Jessica. OK, so Jessica,
what do you think would happen if you went
out to the supermarket and tried to use that
one million dollar bill to pay for your next
batch of groceries?
>>audience #5: They would probably laugh at
me.
>>Chris Chabris: They would probably laugh
at you and they probably wouldn't cash it
for you, right?
>>audience #5: Right.
>>Chris Chabris: OK. So, Jessica is much smarter,
it turns out, than this man, a man who flew
into a rage at the Giant Eagle supermarket
when employees refused to cash a million-dollar
bill.
[laughter]
This was an Associated Press story from Pittsburgh.
Now, it's interesting that a guy went in to
a supermarket and tried to cash a million-dollar
bill. What's more interesting is that he flew
into a rage when they refused to do this,
suggesting that perhaps he thought that they
should, or they would negotiate his million-dollar
bill. I also wonder where he got the million
dollar bill, but in any case. Maybe it was
handed out at a talk he went to.
[laughter]
What this illustrates is a mismatch between
this guy's assessment of his own abilities
and his actual ability. He thinks he's better
at crime than he really is if he thinks he
can get away with this, is this one. According
to Inspector Gareth Woods of the Cheshire
Police, "there are some pretty stupid criminals
around, but to leave your own name at the
scene of the crime takes the biscuit." Now,
the crime was graffiti and it was committed
by someone named Peter Addison, who wrote,
"Peter Addison was here" on a wall. Another
stupid criminal. And then finally, this man.
Lieutenant Terry Hastings said, "I just don't
know why he didn't see a uniformed police
officer standing basically right in front
of him. My guess is he's just not the brightest
of people." Now, what he's referring to is
this gentleman right here, who attempted to
rob a bank where there was a police officer
sitting in the lobby of the bank the entire
time. If you can find this video online, by
the way, it's actually very funny. The police
officer tries to arrest him, but he resists
and they wind up wrestling in the bank and
running around the bank chasing each other
for quite a while. It's very entertaining
surveillance camera footage.
[laughter]
The guy had come in to the bank and cased
it for a couple of minutes before he actually
went up to the teller and tried to rob it
and that whole time the video shows the guy
sitting right there behind the desk, waiting
to catch him. Now, Lieutenant Terry Hastings
is suffering a little bit from the illusion
of attention because as we've all seen, it
is possible to walk around some place and
not notice something important that's happening
in front of you; that's the illusion of attention.
Nonetheless, all these examples illustrate
criminals who seem to think that they're better
at crime than they really are. Now, [pause]
this illustrates the second aspect of the
illusion of confidence, which is that we tend
to overrate our own abilities in various areas.
We're overconfident in our own skills. Let
me try a little test on you to see how overconfident
you are in your own skills. I have a question
that I got that I adapted from a study by
Justin Kruger and David Dunning, two very
clever social psychologists. For each one
of you, I'd like you to think what percent
of Google employees have a worse sense of
humor than your own? Now, I know you're all
here at my talk, so you're probably some of
the funnier people here, but try to be honest
with yourself and think about what percentage
of Google employees have a worse sense of
humor than your own. Just get a number in
your head, what that percentage might be.
And now you've got that percentage, let's
test your own sense of humor and see how funny
you really are. I'm gonna give you two jokes
and would like you to tell me which one is
funnier.
[laughter]
Here's joke one. Question: What is as big
as a man, but weighs nothing? Answer: His
shadow. Joke two. I heard someone laugh.
[laughter]
Joke two. If a kid asks where rain comes from,
I think a cute thing to tell him is "God is
crying." And if he asks why God is crying,
another cute thing to tell him is "probably
because of something you did."
[laughter]
Now, by actual laughter, it seems like most
of you think joke two is funnier than joke
one and you should pat yourselves on the back
because in fact, when Kruger and Dunning presented
these two jokes, as well as a number of other
jokes to a panel of professional comedians,
the professional comedians rated joke two
as the funniest out of the entire group and
joke one as the least funny out of the entire
group. And by using these ratings by professional
comedians, and then giving all these same
jokes to students in their experiment, they
were able to figure out how well student ratings
of funniness of jokes agreed with professional
comedian ratings of funniness of jokes. And
they used those correspondences between the
students and the comedians as a more or less
objective measure of how good the student's
sense of humor was. Now, of course it's really
how well their sense of humor matches that
of a professional comedian, but a professional
comedian is paid to understand what's funny
and to implement that in their own, in their
own act. So, it's not really as bad a test
as you might think. So they compared how funny
people actually were with how funny they thought
they were. And here's what they found. The
straight diagonal line just indicates the
actual test score on this humor test, so those
who were in the bottom quartile, by definition,
scored 12 and a half percent in this test.
And those who were in the second quartile,
by definition, 37 and a half percent and so
on if you just divide them into quartiles.
But notice that the perceived ability, that
is, what percentage of people who they thought
were less funny then they were, is actually
above 50 for all of these groups. And the
largest difference between perceived funniness
and actual funniness is found in those who
were the least funny.
[laughter]
So, this was dubbed by Kruger and Dunning,
the unskilled and unaware of it phenomenon.
That those who were least skilled at something
are least aware of their actual skill level,
or exhibit the greatest discrepancy between
how good they think they are and how good
they really are. Now, of course once again
it's just like the statues before and so on.
This is sense of humor and sense of humor
-- maybe it's not that important, although
I do have to say that it is right up there
in all the personal ads. You always see sense
of humor in all the dating sites and so on,
it's number one. And incidentally, I just
heard of some recent research that is not
published yet, so I don't wanna talk about
it too much, but someone said that sense of
humor is actually one of the best predictors
of how good you are in bed, it turns out.
So, it's really more important than we think
sometimes.
[laughter]
Nonetheless, it is a little bit; it is a little
bit fanciful. Now what about something more
serious and more important, and especially
something more objective, where instead of
using these kind of tests, we really know
how good people are? Are people still overconfident
in their own abilities when they have all
the information they need to truly know how
good they are? Well, Dan Simons and I, along
with Dan Benjamin, who is now an economics
professor at Cornell, a few years ago, did
a study to look at this. We went to the environment
of competitive chess and we visited chess
tournaments like this one. Now, chess is an
interesting arena to study because chess has
an objective statistical rating system that
tells you, in essence, exactly how good you
are, will tell you exactly what your probability
is at beating anyone else based on their rating
and the ratings are frequently updated, players
all know their own ratings and most of them
have a pretty good idea how the ratings are
actually calculated. So, we went to this chess
tournament and asked them two simple questions
of the players. One, what's your current chess
rating? And two, what should your rating be
to accurately reflect your skill?
[laughter]
So, we got two numbers from them and we simply
subtracted them. And it turns out that, on
average, players think that they are significantly
underrated, meaning they think their ratings
should be higher to reflect their true skill.
In fact, they think they are so underrated
that their true self should beat their rated
self by a score of two to one in a match,
which is a really significant difference.
They think they are significantly underrated.
And moreover, those at the lower end of the
rating scale, the worst chess players, think
they are more underrated then those at the
top end of the scale. So, unskilled unaware
of it is not just an artifact of something
where we don't have a good idea how good we
are. It's something that applies even when
we have objective information about our own
skills. It really shows that the illusion
of confidence is part of our self assessment
across the board and is resistant to data
in many ways. Now, that was the illusion of
confidence, and let me move on to a related
illusion, which can be illustrated best by
an experiment by the British psychologist,
Rebecca Lawson. Again, very simple. No high-tech
experiments here today. Rebecca Lawson asked
subjects, how well do you understand how a
bicycle works? Asked them to rate on a scale
of zero to seven how well they understand
how a bicycle works; zero meaning "I have
no idea"; seven meaning "I'm really very knowledgeable
about how bicycles work." And then she surprised
them with the following question: Draw a bicycle,
being sure to show the frame, pedals, and
chain. You might think for a second how well
you could do this task. It's also fun to transpose
the whole situation to a toilet. How well
do you understand how a toilet works, and
now draw the mechanism of a toilet. Now, you
guys, there are probably a lot of engineers
in the audience and so on, so you guys are
probably a bad audience for this thing and
you would do better than the subjects in Lawson's
study. Here's some of what they produced.
[laughter]
These are examples from Lawson's actual paper.
Now, I hear a lot of laughter in the audience.
Perhaps that is because you have noticed that
in all four cases, the chain connects the
two wheels to each other. And also, this is
one of my favorites here, the pedals are suspended--
[laughter]
kind of like a hammock between the two, in
the frame. I don't see how you can possible
power the chain to turn the wheels with that
pedal. At any rate, ironically, drawing C
was actually the most experienced bicycle
rider of these four and yet, she has the chains
connected. She rode an average of once per
day. And what this shows us is that just riding
a bicycle doesn't really necessarily give
us a good idea of its workings, just seeing
it every day. It doesn't really tell us that
much of permanence, it seems. It really sticks
in our minds that we can express in an abstract
way. Probably if you set these people down
in front of a bicycle they would have a much
better idea of how the mechanism works, but
they gave pretty high ratings to the answer
to her question on a zero to seven scale.
So, their intuitive idea about how much they
knew didn't match the reality of how much
knowledge they could actually produce and
use. Now, in an analogy for you guys that
I think is very relevant here, I know now,
thanks in part to your work, we all have access
to tremendous amounts of information, like
literally instantaneously. I mean, I see now,
I don't even have to finish my query before
all the information comes back at me; I get
it after the first three letters. Well, that
can create a powerful sense that I have more
knowledge than I really do because I can access
it so easily. It's in the world around me,
it's at every computer around me now, so one
consequence of that is that we-- oops, sorry
I skipped ahead a little bit-- is that we
may get an overestimate of our own knowledge
because knowledge that's really out in the
world, like in the bicycle or in the toilet
or on the Internet somewhere, we think is
in our own heads because it's easy to access
from outside of us. Now, if you thought bicycles,
which are really pretty simple were hard,
what about this? Now, I don't know if you're
familiar with this particular image, I'll
read it to you. It says "Abacus 2007-AC1.
Two billion dollars synthetic CDO referencing
a static RMBS portfolio, selected by ACM Management,
LLC" and it has the Goldman Sachs logo up
in the corner. This is the famous collateralized
debt obligation that the SEC sued Goldman
Sachs over earlier this year and wound up
settling the case for I believe 550 million
dollar payment. It was very abstract, complex
financial instruments like this that were,
in some ways, at the heart of the financial
crisis of the recent years and the difficulty
people had understanding these, or the belief
they had that they understood them much better
than they did may have contributed to the
difficulties that we all suffered. Retrospectively,
there was some great reporting on the financial
crisis that suggested that really, people
did not understand these things as well as
they thought they did. Now, for example, Vincent
Daniel, at FrontPoint Partners, a hedge fund,
told Michael Lewis that "when talking to CDO
salespeople, you figure out if they even know
what they're talking about, and a lot of times
they don't." And there's a lot of other testimony
that people who bought and sold and traded
these instruments didn't understand them as
well as they thought they did and as a result,
did not understand the risks and bought too
much of this stuff that which, in turn, led
to too much of it being created and so on.
These are examples of what we call the illusion
of knowledge; the idea that our knowledge
and understanding of the world is deeper and
more complete than it really is. Oftentimes,
when you scratch the surface of our knowledge,
it turns out that we have familiarity with
something. We know some terminology and jargon,
but we don't really have deep understanding.
OK. I'm gonna skip the next, skip the next
slide and go straight to our fifth illusion,
which is the illusion of cause. And this is
the idea that we understand cause and effect
better than we do. John Cassidy, writing in
The New Yorker, says, "It is inarguable that
Geithner's stabilization plan has proved more
effective than many observers expected, this
one included." And note what he says. It's
inarguable that something that the government
did in 2009 has proved effective. Now, what's
the evidence we have, really, that something
the government does is effective or has any
particular effect at all? Well, we know what
the conditions were in 2009, and we know what
they are today to the extent we can measure
them in each case what the financial conditions
are and we know that they're different and
better now than they were in 2009. But that
provides no proof that any one particular
action taken in 2009, no matter how well intentioned
or carefully designed, was actually the cause
of the change. Of course, we don't know if
things would have gotten better without that
action or maybe they would have gotten worse
without that action. Maybe they would have
gotten even more better without that action,
or maybe what he did really was effective.
We just don't know, but we assume that when
something is done at time one, and then there's
a change at time two, that what was done at
time one was the cause. And this is the way
we reason causally throughout our lives. We
think that things that happen in sequence
happen because of cause and effect. Often,
that kind of reasoning is purely an illusion
and I can't really explain this any better
really than to show you this example.
[computer beeps]
This really makes the point better than I
possibly can, so I'm gonna turn the talk over
to the Simpsons. OK, so if I were writing
an article about this, I could say, "Well,
it's inarguable that the institution of the
Bear Patrol prevented bears from invading
the town of Springfield." But all I know is
that after the Bear Patrol was started, there
were no more bears and that after I started
carrying around that rock there were no more
tigers and so on. This may seem almost laughable
now that I describe it to you and oftentimes,
when you see these illusions in action, they
seem at once obvious and trivial, but once
again, when you think about this this affects
huge amounts of our decision-making. Now,
we can't always run a randomized experiment
to test the effect of every different kind
of policy we'd want to do, but we shouldn't
just be stalemated and stymied and not try
anything. But we should just realize what
the true strength of our evidence and our
reasons for our beliefs actually is. And a
lot of times, it's lower than we think and
we act as though we're much more certain of
cause and effect than we really are. Now,
let me mention our final, every day illusion,
which is the illusion of potential. As was
mentioned in the introduction, I've studied
the Mozart Effect and the Mozart Effect is
the idea that if you listen to Mozart's music
for ten minutes or so before you take a test,
like an IQ test or an SAT, you'll do better
than you would have if you just sat in silence
or listened to something else, like heavy
metal or whatever. And this was based on a
study that came out in 1993 in the journal
Nature. And as soon as that study came out,
well the CD music companies rushed in to produce
a Mozart [ ] makes you smarter, Train Your
Brain With Mozart, Baby Mozart. The Baby Einstein
Company, which many of you may be familiar
with, especially if you're parents, was founded
around the same time to take advantage of
the notion that this kind of exposure to music
and other works of genius could really have
a powerful effect on our minds. Now, it turns
out they don't. I looked at this later and
it turns out almost no other labs were able
to replicate these initial Mozart Effect findings.
They found pretty much nothing. If there was
a small effect of listening to Mozart before
you did something, it was probably because
it put you in a better mood than just sitting
alone silently for ten minutes did. When you're
in a better mood, you wind up doing a little
bit better on tests and other things you have
to do; nothing really all that shocking about
Mozart. The illusion of potential is the belief
we all have that it's very easy to unlock
our reserves of brain power and mental ability
and skill. Now, we're not saying we don't
have reserves of brain power and mental ability
and skill that we can unlock; it's just not
that easy. You have to do things like study
and practice and get educated and so on. That
is how we increase our skills, not just by
listening to music for ten minutes or playing
video games that are gonna reverse our brain
age and make our minds younger and so on.
What typically happens when you do that is
you get better at the games, but you don't
get much better at anything else. So, if it's
fun for you, go ahead and do it, just don't
believe that it's making your IQ any higher.
Now, I wanna end, I wanna sum up some of what
I've been talking about today by talking about
a self help phenomenon known as The Secret.
I don't know how many of you are familiar
with this idea, but as the cover of the DVD
informs us, The Secret has travelled through
centuries to reach us. The Secret is something,
according to the people who've written these
books, namely in particular, Rhonda Byrne,
an Australian TV producer, The Secret is the
law of attraction. It's another way of saying
the power of positive thinking. If you think
positive thoughts, positive things will come
to you, but if you think negative thoughts,
negative things will come to you. And it really
is that simple; and it really works that way,
according to them. If you think about your
bills and get worried about the bills that
you're having trouble paying, you're gonna
get more bills and you're gonna have more
trouble paying them. But if you think about
getting checks in the mail, or funds deposited
in your bank account, it'll happen. I mean,
it really is that simple. You laugh, but it
really is that simple. That's an example that
comes right out of these books. These books
are on the bestseller list, millions of copies
sold, and so on. Why do people believe this
stuff? Well, it turns out, I think, that these
books are really masterfully exploiting many
of the illusions we've talked about today
and other facts about how the mind works and
notice that travelling through centuries,
these ideas have been around for centuries
in fact. And one of the reasons why these
ideas have succeeded so well is that they
really take advantage of some of the holes
in our rationality that are illustrated by
these illusions. Now, the real secret to The
Secret is based mostly on something called
illusory correlation. So, how many of you
had this experience? You're thinking about
someone who you haven't seen for years and
then suddenly the phone rings and there they
are; you get a message from them. Or, well
I don't know if this has happened to you guys
nowadays, you have good jobs already, but
you went for a job interview and you're thinking
about "boy, I'd really like get that job offer"
and then a few hours later the job offer comes.
And you notice enough of these coincidences
in your life; you might think that you actually
had caused them with your own thoughts. And
I think that's what happens to people that
believe in these ideas. They notice what's
called an illusory correlation. They think
about the times when two things happened together
and they don't think about all of the times
that they weren't thinking about their friend,
but then their friend called. Or the times
that you were thinking about your friend,
but he didn't call or the times, quote unquote,
where you weren't thinking about your friend
and he didn't call, which is pretty much all
of your life.
[laughter]
People don't factor all that stuff into their
calculations of how unusual these events really
are. If they did, they would see that inevitably,
sometime two things are gonna go together;
it's just by chance. The illusion of potential
is also involved here. Wouldn't it be great
if we all did have the potential to massively
change our lives just by thinking positive
thoughts? The illusion of knowledge; there's
all kinds of physics, quantum mechanics mumbo
jumbo that's thrown at us to explain this
stuff and that can create the illusion that
we understand these ideas better than we do.
And then social proof in the argument from
authority that really deploys experts to tell
us that these things are right and show how
many people have believed this, including
supposedly Jesus and various important historical
figures. The idea of The Secret and The Power,
these two books -- is really that they perfectly
exploit every day illusions to convince people
to believe things for which there's zero real
evidence. Now, why did I bring all this stuff
up? Well, these illusions have important consequences.
They're a lot beyond, a lot beyond this. They're
not just trivial interesting facts about how
our minds work; they really affect our every
day behavior. That's why we call them every
day illusions. We're thinking, according to
these illusions, and a lot of the time and
if we become aware of them, we might be able
to make better decisions in a lot of different
areas of our lives. Now, I wanna sum up with
one final message and I'd like to, I'd like
to refer back to Woody Allen's famous stand-up
comedy routine from the 1960s. And he used
to conclude by saying, "Well, I wish I had
an affirmative message to leave you with,
but I don't. So would you settle for two negative
messages?"
[laughter]
Now, I realize that some of these messages
that I've been trying to send you may seem
a little bit negative. Our minds are limited,
we don't pay attention to as much as we think
we do, we don't notice as much, we don't remember
as much, we pay attention to confidence more
than we should, we don't have incredible powers
and so on. Boy, what a downer this guy is.
Well, first of all, I didn't build the mind
this way, I'm just telling you how it actually
is, so don't blame me for that. But two, I
think it's much better to live in the world
if you actually know all that stuff than if
you don't. You can waste incredible amounts
of effort thinking positive thoughts when
you could actually be doing something instead
to get what you want. You can waste, you can
do a lot of bad things if you follow these
illusions too much and you can do a lot of
better things and make better decisions if
you're aware of them. So, that's my final
message, is think about these things and start
to notice how they affect your own behavior
and your own lives and thank you very much.
[applause]
>>presenter: Now we have some time for a few
brief questions if anyone wants to use the
Q&A mic and ask a question.
[pause]
>>audience #6: So the most remarkable thing
about the bike drawings to me was not that
everyone has such a messed up idea about how
bikes work, but everyone drew the exact same
handlebars.
[laughter]
>>Chris Chabris: You're very observant. Actually,
I, what she did in the experiment was she
drew in the handlebars and the seat and so
on and asked them to add the frame and the
chain, the bottom part of the frame and the
chain and the pedals. So, she put the easy
parts in and asked people to fill in the difficult
ones, so that's why the, those top parts all
look the same. I think you'd get similar results
if you ask people to draw from scratch.
>>audience #6: Right. But the simplicity of
the initial drawing probably influenced what
people drew later, right?
>>Chris Chabris: Oh, you mean you think because
it's started out as a simple-looking line
drawing, that that maybe made them do it worse
than they would have otherwise?
>>audience #6: Right. I mean, were they actually
told to draw as accurate as possible, like
technically?
>>Chris Chabris: Oh, well I don't think they
were told to like, make a mechanical drawing
version of it. I don't think that they necessarily
had that skill. I don't think that really
actually matters all that much because no
matter how little drawing skill you have,
you should still be able to not connect the
chain to both wheels, right? I mean, that's
like a functional error more than a drawing
or an artistic error. Right. But yeah, you
did definitely notice the, that it wasn't
exactly the way I described it; I simplified
it a little bit.
>>audience #6: Thanks.
>>Chris Chabris: Who's next?
>>audience #7: You wanna come up?
>>Chris Chabris: OK, how about the guy at
the mic first?
>>audience #7: OK, so going back to the bicycle
experiment, you in an offhand way you said
that perhaps that the fact that people have
access to more information than they used
to have means that what we think that we have
more information internally than we actually
do, and I was wondering if you could explore
that more in the book or if you could just
elaborate more on that if you see like, is
there any study where people don't have access
to libraries or computers or say like, you
talk to people who ride their bicycle every
day versus somebody who doesn't ride a bicycle,
if you could just talk some more about that.
>>Chris Chabris: Yeah, that's a really good
question. I did throw that in as kind of an
offhand observation and the reason why I did
was that we haven't actually done any studies
on this. I think it would be really interesting
to do some cognitive psychology research on
what's the measurable effect of having more
or less access to information about a particular
topic. How does that affect how much, how
well you think you understand that and so
on and I can't really, I can't really tell
you what the results would be because we haven't
actually done that yet, so it's more of a
hypothesis than a subtle conclusion. And I
don't mean to say, by the way, that having
access to more information, heaven forbid
in this building, to say that having access
to more information is a bad thing. I think
it's undoubtedly, overall an extremely great
thing, but there may be some side effects
on our perception of how much we actually
understand. And I base this partly on my observation
of students sometimes that it's easy for students
in courses to think they understand things
better than they really do and I think part
of the reason for that is that the information
is so accessible. Not only is there a textbook,
but they can look things up on Wikipedia and
now we put our PowerPoint slides online, they
go to lectures and so on. The information
comes at them in a lot of different forms
a lot of the time, but I don't think it necessarily
helps them understand how well they understand
the topic. They still say after they did badly
on the test, they say, "Well, how did I do
so badly on the test? I really looked at all
that information." And so on. But I definitely
agree that this is a very fruitful area for
more experiments that I would like to work
on.
>>audience #7: But so you seem to be suggesting
that you think that somehow easier access
to information is making people conflate,
I don't know, like--
>>Chris Chabris: What's in their head with
what's out in the world?
>>audience #7: Or maybe in the last example,
like facts with some, I don't know, deep understanding
or--
>>Chris Chabris: Yeah, essentially yes -- that
the easier it is to access information the
harder it is to tell the difference between
information that we actually know and information
that we can easily retrieve. That's, that's
the hypothesis. And you look skeptical, which
I think is good.
[Chris laughs]
Cause it definitely hasn't been, it definitely
hasn't been tested extensively. I think it's
an interesting hypothesis for investigation.
>>audience #7: Thank you.
>>Chris Chabris: Thanks. There was someone
over here, or maybe he's over, back over here
now. Oh, OK. Yeah?
>>audience #8: I just had a question about
that million dollar bill you gave to her.
[Chris laughs]
I've seen videos of, I don't know how real
these videos are, they're from some like,
mentalist guy, but he like, pays for things
with blank, with like white paper--
>>Chris Chabris: Mm-hmm.
>>audience #8: that's roughly in the shape
of dollar bills. And I was just, I mean, is
that the same thing?
>>Chris Chabris: I haven't seen the videos
you're talking about, but I suspect what's
going on there is that if you distract the
people in certain ways from what you're doing,
they may just take what you hand them and
stick them in the cash register or something
like that. Now, of course, if this guy wanted
to buy a milkshake with a million-dollar bill,
he probably could have got away with it. It
was the expecting change that was the problem
and in order to get your change from a million-dollar
bill, the cashier's gotta look at it and see
that it's a million-dollar bill and so on.
So, I don't think it's exactly the same--
>>audience #8: Sure.
>>Chris Chabris: but in a way, a lot of what
mentalists do and magicians, of course, is
manipulate your attention. So, they manipulate
what you're paying attention to and what you're
thinking about at any particular time, it's
very easy with all the stuff that we can miss
in the world to imagine that we could miss
actually what we're stuffing in the cash register
or something like that. Thanks.
>>audience #9: So, in the experiments that
you did, you mentioned that there were some
people who were perceptive, who noticed that
experimenters had changed or whatever.
>>Chris Chabris: Mm-hmm.
>>audience #9: I was wondering if there was
anything else about these people. Were they
happier? Were they sadder? Were they miserable?
Had they had three divorces? I don't know
anything that you might have come up with.
>>Chris Chabris: Well, we didn't test a three
divorce hypothesis.
[laughter]
That might correlate with the happiness or
sadness. In general, the answer is that nothing
has been found that at all strongly predicts
whether people notice unexpected things in
inattentional blindness experiments or noticed
changes in change blindness experiments. Things
you think might, like their working memory
capacity, how much stuff can they maintain
in memory at one time, doesn't seem to. Dan
Simons has been doing some research on this.
I even, by the way, ran a study where we included
the gorilla test, along with a lot of other
tests and then we got DNA from the subjects
and looked to see if there were any genes
that the gorilla noticers had that the missers
didn't and we didn't find anything. But, of
course, it's very hard to find, find genes
for things like that so I was a little bit
quixotic, but Dan has found maybe some faint
hints that personality variables might affect
it, but they're extremely small effects and
hard to see so that your success or failure
at noticing something is really a bad personality
test, a really bad measure of anything. And
I think most of it is circumstance and luck
and whatever's happen, whatever's going on
in your brain at that time and so on. There's,
you know? I hesitate to just call it random
because there's nothing truly random, but
from our point of view it would be random.
Thanks.
>>audience #10: I have another question about
the million-dollar bill experiment. So, you
use that as an example, or at least the way
I interpret it, you used it as an example
of somebody whose perception of their skill
at deceiving was far off from their actual
skill and they--
>>Chris Chabris: Or for his skill at crime,
yeah.
>>audience #10: Yeah. But isn't it possible,
I guess the way I interpret it when I saw
that, was that maybe he used his anger at
not receiving change as an additional projection
of confidence that it was valid and that he
should be receiving money back.
>>Chris Chabris: Well, that's certainly possible
and sometimes when I get angry at a customer
service person, it helps a little bit.
>>audience #10: Right.
>>Chris Chabris: Yeah, that's a possible explanation
and I like that you called it the million-dollar
bill experiment cause we didn't actually do
an experiment with million-dollar bills. It
would be interesting to do that. You've given
me an idea just now, so what we'll have to
include you as a co-author if we do a million-dollar
bill experiment. I think there may be something
to what you're saying and I have to say in
honesty, I used it in part for the humor value,
but you can easily find lists of all these
stupid -- Google stupid crimes and you'll
get a lot of them. And I can't help but think
that one thing that's going on in these cases
is that the criminals think they're better
at crime than they really are. Now, there
are probably other things happening, too,
like "where did this guy get the million-dollar
bill and how did he think he came into it
without paying for it with a million dollars"
or something like that. So, there's obviously
more to the story and maybe you're right about
that he was just trying to really like, wow
them with even more confidence.
>>audience #10: Yeah, I don't know.
>>Chris Chabris: Could be.
>>audience #10: Thinking about it.
[pause]
>>audience #11: Hi. Interesting talk, I loved
it.
>>Chris Chabris: Thank you.
>>audience #11: You mentioned the distinction
between what we know in the head and what
we can infer from the environment.
>>Chris Chabris: Right.
>>audience #11: And these days, more and more
of our knowledge or whatever we know is shifted
onto things we carry, like cell phones.
>>Chris Chabris: Mm-hmm.
>>audience #11: Like, ten years ago, if you
ask someone to give, speak out the five closest
people's phone numbers, they could do that.
>>Chris Chabris: Right.
>>audience #11: Today, I don't think anyone
would be able to cite those numbers.
>>Chris Chabris: Right.
>>audience #11: So, it's all just [ ] cognition,
so do we really need to make a distinction
between what's in the head versus what's with
me?
>>Chris Chabris: Right, so this is an excellent
question. What is this boundary between the
head and this boundary right here that's made
up of bone and skin and so on. Is that really
cognitively significant anymore, as significant
as it used to be? And I think the answer is
no. To some, it's not as, it's not completely
unimportant, it's not irrelevant, but it's
not as important for the reason you say. And
maybe we should start to, instead of studying
the individual, abilities of the individual
as much as we did, which is the traditional
way in cognitive psychology and cognitive
neuroscience, start to study the abilities
of the human computer or the human device
partnership, or the human Internet partnership
or of groups of people working together which
increasingly happens in workplaces much more
than it used to. And I actually, I started
doing a little bit of research on that myself
where I did something really trivial. I had
people do an IQ test, not an IQ test, sorry.
I had them do a GRE, a standardized test with
or without a computer that they had access
to just for fun to see what would happen and
how much smarter do they get when they have
a computer. And it turns out, good news. They
do better. But maybe not, maybe not as much
better as you might think and it might differ
depending on what kind of materials they are
and so on. And so I think we, that's a very
faint first step at starting to study exactly
the phenomenon you're talking about and move
that into what psychologists study when they
study intelligence and human abilities and
so on. It's a good suggestion.
>>presenter: [inaudible]
>>Chris Chabris: The million-dollar question
was coming, though.
>>presenter: Oh, it's really quick.
>>Chris Chabris: She gets to ask one cause
she got the million-dollar bill.
>>audience #12: Yeah, it's really quick. I
was wondering, in the experiments that you
do with people looking for the gorilla or
the one with the umbrella or whatever, have
you guys ever gone into biology, neurobiology
to see what parts of the brain's actually,
are stimulated in the people that do see them?
And how does that differ?
>>Chris Chabris: Well, the answer, the answer
is for these kinds of experiments generally,
no. We haven't done that and part of the reason
for that is that it's a methodological challenge
to repeat these experiences enough times that
you can get enough data to really answer those
questions. Once people know there's a gorilla
coming, it's hard to redo the same thing again.
There has been research on what goes on in
the brain when we pay attention to one thing
and ignore other things, but we haven't, that's
not stuff that we've actually done ourselves.
Thanks.
>>presenter: Chris, that was an amazing talk,
thank you very much for speaking with us.
>>Chris Chabris: Thank you.
[applause]